الينا من بيروت العميد الياس حنا الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي اهلا بك عميد الياس
نبدا وهذا الجدل بخصوصها روسيا تقول انها
تقدمت سبعه كيلومترات واوكرانيا تنفيذ كيف
انت تقرا الوضع
اليوم ليس هناك من هجوم شامل وكامل
بالمعنى الشامل على كما حصل في خاركاب منذ
اكثر من شهرين اليوم هي عمليه تحسين مواضع
تحسين مواقع تكتيكيه اليوم سبعه كيلو متر
هذا بالمعنى المساحات الكبيره هو شيء قليل
جدا اهميه ذا فولوجيا بالمرحله القادمه هي
عمليه تحسين الوضع التكتيكي اما للدفاع او
حتى للوجوم في مرحله لاحقه في مرحله الحرب
التي يحضر لها ولا اين البارحه الاجتماع
خلال مشتعل والاجتماع في بروكسل هذه
الامور كلها يحضر لها فروج يعني هم اللي
عده اسباب اولا فيها انرجي» ال- ال-
المحطه النوويه مدينه مليتو بول التي تحمي
منطقه خرسان حيث يتواجد العسكر همم الروسي
فاذا هذه العمليات هي عمليه تحضيريه
لحمايه المجنونه وبالتالي تجنب اي هجوم
مفاجئ من قبل قوات الاكرانيه ماذا عن
سوليدار واخر اا التطورات اا فيها اا
التلفزيون من الروسي يقول ان قوات ضاقنر
سيطرت على بلده صول ما اهميه هذه البلده
وماذا تعني هذه السيطره
ايضا وسيله سوليدار بالمعنى الاستراتيجي
الكبير ليست مهمه بحد ذاتها هي وسيله لقطع
الامدادات عن بخموط وبالتالي تحضير اسقاط
مدينه بخمود منطقه سوريا
ولكن ما نفع سكك الحديد اذا كانت كل
المنطقه مدمره ضمن الالبوم التحتيه بخموت
هي المحطه او نقطه الصله او نقطه وصل لكل
السكك الحديد ولكن باموت مدمره ما نفع
الاهميه الاستراتيجيه لهذه المدينه
المرحله القادمه هي مرحله قطع بعض هي قطع
همم خطوط المواصلات عن مخموت محاوله
اسقاطها وبالتالي التحضير للمرحله القادمه
لمدينتين مهمنتين جدا جدا هو همم همم
صبيانس والكلام التونسي وبذلك يكون الرئيس
بوتين حقق اهم هدف له اقليم الدنباز والذي
كانت الحرب بسببه في البدايه وهو المرحله
القادمه ربما الانظار تتجه فيها الى
الدبابات التي يثار حولها الجدل المنح او
عدم منح اوكرانيا اذا استمر هذا الجدل ولم
تمنح اوكرانيا هذه الدبابات كيف سنعكس ذلك
على الارض كيف
تستفيد روسيا من ذلك ميدانيه
الدبابات ستعطى من بريطانيا الدبابات
قطاعتها من الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
الدبابات قد تعطي لاحقا من دوله لديها
اللي يقال حتى لو وافقت او لم توافق
المانيا وهذا ما اقترحه وزير رئيس الوزراء
البولندي المرحله القادمه وسيله هي مرحله
تحديد هجوم حسب ما قالها يعني قال هو وزير
الدفاع الامريكي اليوم هناك عربات مدرعه
مهمه لنقل العسكر الى الجبهه هناك حمايه
جويه وبالتالي تاتي الدبابه كمدفع كعمليه
صدمه لحمايه هذه
المدرعات هناك مدرعات كثيره يجب ان ننتظر
لمرحله قادمه وقد يكون لالمانيا اسباب
عديده لعدم اعطائها الا يطارد شكرا جزيلا
لك العميد الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
حدثنا من بيروت